là vous voyez la porte du bureau de
l'éditeur il ne sait pas que vous êtes
là mais il sera immédiatement pourquoi
vous êtes là ça fait une belle lurette
que vous auriez dû toucher vos droits
d'auteur et il ne répond même plus à vos
emails
alors vous poussez très doucement la
porte tant qu'éditeur ne se rend compte
de rien et dès qu'il vous aperçoit vous
lui foncer dessus vous sauter par dessus
le bureau et vous lui faites un
étranglement
alors comme ça on oublie mes droits
d'auteur ils sont pas assez faibles
comme ça 0 c'est mieux c'est ça euros
par don aristote sait pas exactement ce
que recommande jack london
mais c'est un peu ça dans cette vidéo je
vais vous donner les dix conseils de
jack london le génial autodidacte
américain pour devenir écrivain
je suis romain voici aristote qui joue
le rôle de l'éditeur et vous êtes sûr
mais l'idée de culture générale
[Musique]
comment devenir écrivain quelles sont
les choses concrètes à faire pour
réussir ce qui est très rare à vivre de
sa plume
jack london nous dit comment il s'y est
pris lui dans profession écrivain une
compilation de 93 textes issus de ces
correspondances ou d'articles qu'il
avait écrit pour de petites revues
je l'avais lu il ya pile dix ans et j'ai
relu récemment parce qu'il est
maintenant disponible sur kindle comme
je le fais systématiquement depuis les
quelques vidéos précédentes je vous
permet de télécharger mes notes de
lecture en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou sur celui
qui est dans la description puis en me
laissant votre adresse email les
conseils de jack london sont d'autant
plus précieux qu'il est parti de tout en
bas lui issu d'un milieu très populaire
il a quitté l'école très tôt pour
travailler
il a vécu dans la pauvreté sans savoir
s'ils pourraient manger à sa faim
et malgré l'ampleur de l'adversité il a
réussi à devenir un des romanciers les
plus importants de son époque est
probablement un des plus grands auteurs
américains
le site rencker le classent huitième
meilleur écrivain américain de tous les
temps et le journal britannique le
telegraph a classé son roman l'appel de
la forêt l'histoire d'un chien
domestique qui redevient sauvage ça me
fait penser à aristote même si je ne
donne pas cher de sa peau dans une forêt
donc vos telegraph a classé l'appel de
la forêt cinquième meilleur roman
nord-américain de tous les temps et
enfin autre chose que j'ai découverte
récemment la bibliothèque de la pléiade
a accueilli jack london en 2016 une
consécration qui veut un peu dire qu'il
est considéré comme un des plus grands
auteurs tout court et je rappelle que
jack london s'est lancé dans l'aventuré
littéraire sans avoir fait d'études sans
mentor ni réseau contre l'avis de tout
son entourage qui était très populaire
et enfin sans argent donc si quelqu'un
de bon conseil pour devenir écrivain
c'est bien lui
alors j'ai synthétiser les
recommandations qui sont dans ce livre
et je suis arrivé à une liste de dix
conseils qui sont à la fois pratique
précis c'est vraiment de l'or en toute
franchise
si je n'ai pas précisément mon ambition
de devenir écrivain
j'applique moi même les conseils de jack
london parce qu'ils sont très efficaces
dans cette vidéo je vais vous les
présenter dans l'ordre dans lequel le
débutant devrait les appliquer pour
devenir écrivain
c'est à dire un ordre de priorité et
puis je vous révélerai dans le 10e et
dernier conseil
pourquoi il peut être nécessaire
d'apprendre un sport de combat pour les
rendez-vous avec l'éditeur donc regardez
bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout allez on
rentre dans le vif du sujet conseil
numéro un
mettez un pouce bleus et abonnez vous si
vous voulez que je relâche l'éditeur
[Musique]
le premier conseil de jack london
ça ne vous étonnera pas c'est de lire
beaucoup bah oui l'écrivain est d'abord
un leaser jack london a appris à lire à
5 ans et étant donné ses moyens modestes
il a emprunté beaucoup d'ouvragés dans
les bibliothèques publiques avant d'être
en mesure d'en acquérir
il avait toujours un livre avec lui ce
n'était pas comme un dans son milieu
social et il a même pris l'habitude à
l'âge adulte de passer les dernières
heures de la journée avec des livres
dans son lit plus généralement pour
devenir écrivain
il faut étudier se cultiver tout au long
de la vie dans ce travail intellectuel
il faut notamment analyser l'état de la
littérature de l'époque dans le but de
modéliser les écrivains professionnels
c'est-à-dire de reprendre les principes
et les recettes qui ont fait leur succès
est un principe en particulier est
cruciale
[Musique]
je livre toujours la copie promise
affirme jack london - ça c'est clair
c'est que l'autodidacte américain est
très discipliné à ses yeux l'écrivain
professionnel est un homme comme les
autres il doit se plier à la discipline
d'un métier cette discipline elle a
quatre composantes principales la
première c'est la régularité
l'aspirante écrivains ne doit pas
attendre l'inspiration il doit la
harceler en se mettant au travail
quel que soit son niveau de motivation
imposez-vous une besogne et veiller à
l'accomplir chaque jour vous aurez plus
de moi votre crédit à la fin de l'année
jack london recommande plus précisément
décrire mille mots par jour à condition
que ces mots soient les meilleurs qu'on
puisse trouver pourquoi mille mots parce
qu en dessous les choses n'avancent pas
assez vite et côte dessus la qualité de
la production littéraire baissent
rapidement
si vous avez regardé ma vidéo sur les
règles d'écriture de stephen king
vous vous rappelez peut-être qu'il écrit
lui deux mille mots chaque jour la
différence et je crois que jack london
miss peut être davantage sur la qualité
deuxième composante de la discipline de
l'écrivain écrire une seule histoire à
la fois jack london propose la méthode
suivante vous noircissez vaut mille mots
chaque jour sans penser au résultat
final et cela pendant 60 jours
et puis cette méthode s'insère dans une
stratégie plus globale
vous faites des tests successifs de 90
jours de moins de travail puis un mois
de repos guillemets pour récupérer et
réfléchir
troisième composante prendre des notes
vous devez toujours avoir un carnet de
notes à portée de main mieux il doit
être comme une extension de votre corps
aujourd'hui un smartphone et une
application de prise de notes
moi j'utilise evernote par exemple c'est
quand même bien pratique
quatrième et dernière composante de la
discipline de l'écrivain rester en bonne
santé
c'est même crucial pour mettre en
pratique le conseil suivant
[Musique]
le talent ça n'existe pas la seule chose
en laquelle crohas jack london c'est le
labeur acharné le travail et tout c'est
la sanctification et le salut écrivait
ce mot en majuscules travaille travaille
tout le temps
le débutant doit d'autant plus charbonné
qu'il est peut être dans la même urgence
économique que jack london à ses débuts
d'ailleurs s'il n'a pas les moyens de se
consacrer à l'écriture plein temps il ne
faut pas qu'il quitte son emploi il faut
plutôt qu'ils misent sur l'intensité et
la régularité du travail pour compenser
le manque de temps mais la raison
principale pour laquelle il faut
travailler comme un fou c'est que
l'éditeur n'a pas envie de vous donner
votre chance pour réduire le risque
économique
il privilégie les auteurs qui ont déjà
un an c'est à dire une base de lecteurs
fidèles donc l'auteur inconnu lui doit
forcément proposer un travail mais une
qualité supérieure
telle qu'elle compense son absence de
notoriété initial il faut donc
travailler comme un fou pour devenir
écrivain
après il ne faut pas non plus signalé la
tête dans le guidon
[Musique]
comme il a commencé dans la pauvreté
jack london est assez pragmatique
l'écriture est une activité commerciale
avec des producteurs et des
consommateurs
alors certes il existe des auteurs qui
croient à l'art pour l'art qui sont là
pour délivrer un message mais ils sont
généralement à l'abri du besoin
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la majorité
des aspirants écrivains
le débutant qui doit remplir son frigo
n'a pas le choix de sa démarche
économique il doit partir du besoin du
marché
pour jack london l'écrivain est un
marchand d'idées et l'argent n'est donc
pas un tabou pour lui il met sur le
marché des productions commerciales
typiquement de fiction ce qui se vend le
mieux
et surtout pas des essais ou de la
poésie dans le détail l'aspirant
d'écrivains a aussi intérêt à conformer
son histoire à certains critères pour en
maximiser la valeur commerciale
chaque jeune conseil entre autres de
s'inspirer systématiquement de la
réalité de rendre le récit réaliste
quitte à choquer le bourgeois de
développer la psychologie des
personnages ou encore éventuellement de
s'appuyer sur une idéologie qui est dans
l'air du temps
inutile en revanche d'aspirer diffuser
la vérité si le but est de vendre des
livres c'est qu'on a tendance d'après
jack london a sous-estimé l'inculture de
la masse démocratique des électeurs
il s'exprime d'ailleurs assez crûment
sur ce point c'est le troupeau où règne
la fantaisie et le caprice la marotte et
la mode c'est la masse instable
incohérente par alan thé pensant comme
la foule
les singes excusez moi du temps présent
donc manifestement il n'est pas
nécessaire de respecter son lectorat
pour lui vendre beaucoup de livres
[Musique]
quand on s'engage dans la carrière des
lettres il ne faut pas chercher à écrire
un classique simplement travailler avec
humilité pour progresser et en
particulier pour améliorer son style
aucun éditeur ne donnera sa chance à un
débutant sous prétexte qu'il fait de
gros efforts et si lui donne sa chance
pour cette raison il commet une faute
pas une fois de morale mais une faute
économique
à l'époque de jack london vous pouvez
commencer de deux manières différentes
la première la plus brillante c'était
d'écrire directement un livre à succès
et la seconde la plus sûre celle qui a
choisi l'autodidacte américain
c'était de se démarquer d'abord avec de
bonnes nouvelles dans les magazines donc
jack london a commencé petit il a
d'abord accompli beaucoup de besogne
littéraire pour gagner sa vie
en plus personne ne l'avait donc il n'a
pu avancer que par essai erreur
à côté il participait aussi à des
concours littéraires parfois il gagnait
sa vie donner bon espoir
or il n'ya pas dix mille moyens de
réussir en comment ce petit il faut
persévérer
[Musique]
j'ai hésité à fusionner ce conseil avec
le troisième travaillé comme un fou mais
je trouve finalement que ce n'est pas la
même chose de travailler intensément et
puis de réussir à la faire dans la durée
en dépit de l'accumulation des obstacles
et des échecs
et puis jack london insiste bien sur ce
point
non seulement l'aspirant d'écrivains va
devoir travailler comme un fou mais
surtout il ne va pas être publiés au
bout d'une semaine
enfin si ça existe mais ça s'appelle la
publication à compte d'auteur et savon
film parfois à l'escroquerie mais bon
c'est pas le sujet pour devenir un vrai
écrivain il faut un coeur de lion pour
persévérer dans l'adversité
jack london lui à ses débuts il
n'arrêtait pas décrire et à peu près de
tout il essuyé refus sur refus au point
qu'il n'avait plus de timbres pour
répondre lorsqu'il a finalement reçu les
premières lettres positive des
rédacteurs en chef
ce qui est très difficile c'est de
maintenir au long cours à un rythme de
production élevés sans compromettre la
qualité
il ne faut pas se satisfaire de ces
travaux et les a envoyés pour les
envoyer sans être certain d'avoir traqué
puis corrigé la moindre des
imperfections et même après avoir tout
corriger il ne faut pas être satisfait
le débutant ambitieux doit développer
son perfectionnisme celui qui n'est pas
satisfaits et le seul à faire des choses
celui qui est satisfait ne fait rien
l'absence de satisfaction et le
stimulant de la réalisation la
satisfaction et destruction est
l'antichambre de la mort en fait c'est
pareil dans tous les domaines
les meilleurs travaillent sans relâche
ils se perdent dans le travail jusqu'à
ce que les honneurs lors tout le dessus
et que leurs noms soient sur toutes les
lèvres
vous vous souvenez des tests de 90 jours
dont j'ai parlé à propos de la
discipline de l'écrivain et bien jack
london ne recommande d'en mener pendant
au moins cinq ans
[Musique]
il faut bien autant de temps pour
apprendre un métier manuel
mais c'est vrai que le niveau de
persévérance nécessaires pour devenir
écrivain est probablement bien supérieur
c'est dans son roman autobiographique
martin eden que jack london a décrit la
persévérance surhumaine dont il a dû
faire preuve et toutes les déceptions
qui l'aï prouvé avant de finalement
réussir à convaincre li rédacteur en
chef et les éditeurs jack london et
surtout reconnu pour ses histoires
d'aventurés des histoires originales qui
font voyager le lecteur mais l'histoire
ne fait pas tout il faut la transmettre
dans la forme la plus agréable possible
l'aspirante écrivain doit donc
travailler son style or la qualité de
l'écriture découle de celle de la pensée
l'amélioration du style passe donc par
celle de la pensée est pour ça j'en ai
parlé d'un premier conseil il faut lire
et étudier toute l'année mais dans
l'immédiat pour le style il faut encore
partir du ce que veut le public que
demande le lecteur moderne que l'auteur
entre très vite dans le vif du sujet que
l'histoire ne foisonnent pas de détails
superflus et qu'on le laisse utiliser
son imagination qu'on lui épargne les
digressions philosophiques ou morale en
plein milieu du récit le lecteur moderne
est un adulte qui réfléchit de manière
indépendante comme jack london et
darwinisme
il rapporte l'évolution du style
littéraire axel de l'espèce or le moteur
de l'évolution de l'espèce c'est la
recherche de l'efficience c'est-à-dire
de l'économie de temps de la même
manière que le progrès technique
raccourci les processus en simplifiant
le style littéraire dévolu par la
concentration et la concision à
l'allégorie c'est à dire l'expression
d'un concept
une histoire se substitue la métaphore
qui se contente d'une image incarner
l'idée un autre phénomène notable de
cette évolution du style c'est la
disparition progressive des pléonasmes
et sur le plan statistique
l'évolution se traduit par une baisse
continue du nombre de mots par phrase ça
c'est l'évolution au niveau micro comme
disent les économistes
mais elle se retrouve aussi au niveau
macro c'est-à-dire à l'échelle du livre
l'ère du roman fleuve en plusieurs
volumes comme les misérables qui fait
1300 pages cette ère est révolue
les romans de l'époque de jack london
font entre 40000 et 60 mille mots de
telle sorte qu'ils peuvent être lues
d'une seule traite
et je crois que c'est encore la norme
pour les romans actuels donc bien sûr le
conseil de jack london
c'est d'épouser l'air du temps pour
donner aux lecteurs exactement ce qu'il
veut après il rappelle quand même
certaines règles élémentaires qui sont
intemporels notamment diversifier le
vocabulaire pour éviter les répétitions
varier les structures de phrases faire
l'effort de chercher des images ou
encore réalisé les auditions avec
finesse si on veut vraiment soigné le
style donner une forme agréable au récit
ça implique l'échelle projet livre de ne
pas écrire en une seule traite
il faut laisser mûrir le manuscrit la
particularité du processus créatif de
jack london
c'est qu'il essaye d'atteindre un niveau
élevé de qualité le plus tôt possible
pour ça il rédige très lentement à la
main ensuite il corrige son premier jet
en dactylographiées le manuscrit
ce qui fait qu'il a une version quasi
finale en seulement deux étapes de
production
il modifie très rarement les épaules
[Musique]
pour jack london l écrivain à succès a
forcément une véritable originalité et
cette originalité c'est une forme de
sincérité qu'il puise dans son
expérience vécue et dans la réalité
factuelle
c'est sa philosophie delà de tout
écrivain ayant du succès de façon
permanente à posséder cette philosophie
l'écrivain digne de ce nom à sa propre
manière de voir le monde
une manière certes subjective et pas
forcément enseigne abl mais si
particulière qu'elle produit un
élargissement de la conscience du
lecteur cette subjectivité inédite
c'est même le fil conducteur de son
oeuvre si ce qui peut s'il est en
résonance avec l'époque lui donner une
portée universelle et la rendre ainsi
immortel on voit avec ce conseil que si
jack y ont donné très pragmatique il
reconnaît quand même une forme de
transcendance à l'écriture bon après
comment développer sa philosophie de la
vie il faut d'abord élargir ses
perspectives sur l'existence en
cultivant à la fois la connaissance et
l'expérience peser la main sur le pou
intérieur des choses
cris jack london alors c'est sûr que ça
ne va pas se produire en regardant
netflix
la tâche est immense mais on gaspille
tellement de temps et puis c'est le prix
de la richesse et du prestige
[Musique]
bon on ne va pas se mentir
l'aspirant et l'écrivain ne se met pas à
la littérature parce que les muses sont
venus le voir la nuit dernière dans 99%
des cas ici mais par ambition il est
attiré par l'aisance financière et où le
prestige des auteurs à succès ensuite
quand il commence sa première obsession
c'est de vivre de sa plume
mais bon l'obsession est la même dans
toute la chaîne de production
le propriétaire du journal celui de la
maison d'édition le rédacteur en chef
l'éditeur les correcteurs les critiques
et puis même les lecteurs tout le monde
a la même motivation
donc il faut l'accepter chacun donne lui
n'a aucun problème avec ça en ancien
pauvre il défend le bien être matériel
de l'écrivain professionnel lui même une
veille à ses intérêts avec un certain
sens des affaires il négocie son tarif
habituellement 10 cents le mot
systématiquement à la hausse dès qu'il
peut il compte plusieurs mots au lieu
d'un seul
et puis ils contestent par principe le
décompte de l'éditeur enfin il n'hésite
pas à monnayer sa renommée par exemple
quand il démarche des magazines pour
financer ses voyages en leur proposant
de sponsoriser son bateau à prix d'or il
ne leur fait vraiment pas de cadeau mais
bon il faut assumer laquelle du prestige
parce qu'il est méritée après tant
d'efforts qu'ils soient matérialiste oui
la liste aucun écrivain normale n'est
insensible aux avantages attachés à sa
possession
jack london n'a pas de mots assez durs
pour décrire les hypocrites
ce sont des sophistes et des dégénérés
pour autant le débutant ne doit pas
chercher à réussir à n'importe quel prix
il doit refuser la promotion par les
scandales le sacrifice de la qualité
littéraire un profit rapide ou encore
une starification artificiel toute la
difficulté pour lui sera de satisfaire
le public en restant fidèle à sa
philosophie de la vie
[Musique]
imaginons qu'aristote soit un éditeur
l'âge il a assez souffert comme ça et
puis il ne serait jamais aussi durs qu'a
rédacteur en chef
l'éditeur ces hommes ont tellement fait
souffrir jack london
il les qualifie de criminels et ils
énumèrent leurs crimes répondre beaucoup
trop tard à l'aspirant d'écrivains ne
pas lui répondre et laisser moisir le
manuscrit pendant des mois
s'il daigne lire le manuscrit il la note
tellement qu ils le rendent
inutilisables
parfois au miracle il l'envoie
directement à l'imprimerie mais sans
fournir un exemplaire à l'auteur ou sans
respecter le délai de paiement ou sans
avoir obtenu son accord sur les tarifs
voix en décidant que c'est une
contribution gratuite
les rédacteurs en chef de magazines sont
des hommes d'affaires du mur et sans
principes
si jack london est conscient de la lea
qui pèse sur le succès d'un livre
il part du principe que les rédacteurs
en chef et les éditeurs ont pour
objectif de s'enrichir sur son dos or
seuls les écrivains de premier ordre
réussi à inverser le rapport de force
par exemple jack london vendée
suffisamment de livres pour se permettre
de refuser les corrections de ces
éditeurs qui trouvait souvent excessive
ou erronées en revanche son succès ne le
rendait pas moins impuissant face à la
malhonnêteté des critiques littéraires
qui sont considérés comme les juges de
la valeur finale de l'oeuvre avec lui
comme avec les autres ils ne font pas
sérieusement leur travail quand il ne
s'épargne pas purement et simplement
l'étape de la lecture
jackson ne raconte par exemple qu'un
critique a écrit un éloges enthousiastes
de certaines de ses nouvelles sur la
ruée vers l'or en croyant qu'il
s'agissait l'histoire de mr et le pire
dans tout ça c'est que comme les
critiques ne font pas leur travail
certains écrivant lui demande alors à
lui de se muer en critique pour ensuite
lui reprocher sa franchise
bref rédacteur en chef et
critiquée même écrivain il n'y en a pas
un pour rattraper l'autre
donc méfiance
[Musique]
en
en synthèse pour devenir écrivain il
faut lire et étudier permanence être
discipliné travaillé comme un fou partie
des besoins du public commençait petit
persévérer cultivé un style simple et
efficace
avoir une philosophie de vie assumer la
quête de la richesse et du prestige et
enfin se méfier du monde de la
littérature alors lydie conseil de jack
london rejoignent ceux donnés par
d'autres grands auteurs comme ceux de
stephen king que j'ai synthétisée dans
une autre vidéo que vous pouvez voir
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite soit sur
celui qui est dans la description donc
les conseils de jack london sont
cohérents avec l'expérience commune de
l'écrivain professionnel défini comme la
personne qui réussit à vivre de sa plume
mais il se démarque quand même par un
grand pragmatisme en autodidacte parvenu
à la gloire littéraire à la force du
poignet il s'exprime sans tabou il parle
de marché littéraire il insulte son
lectorat
il justifie l'ambition de l'écrivain son
esprit mercantile et sa vanité
ils dénoncent la corruption du monde
littéraire c'est que comme je les lis en
introduction il a eu lui qui est parti
de si bas à déplacer des montagnes pour
s'imposer
son ascension a été si dure que la
profession d'écrivain en et des listes
eefje devenir écrivain c'est un peu un
projet comme un autre son
accomplissement tient en définitive à un
mélange de réalisme et de persévérance
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au
bout j'espère vraiment que les conseils
de jack london peuvent vous aider dans
vos projets d'écriture
si la vidéo vous a plu et surtout si
vous voulez récompenses et aristote dans
son rôle de l'éditeur agressé par
l'auteur vous pouvez donner un pouce
bleus à la vidéo vous abonner à la
chaîne si vous aimez la vulgarisation de
la pensée et enfin peut-être laisser un
petit commentaire
je vous permet également de télécharger
mes notes de lecture comme je le fais
systématiquement depuis les quelques
vidéos précédentes
si vous voulez lire ma synthèse écrite
détaillée du livre qui est sur le blog
ou si vous souhaitez le lire directement
tous les liens sont dans la description
je suis romain je suis avec mon fidèle
aristote qui est quand même bien plus
gentil qu'un éditeur et vous étiez sur
milliers de culture générale vous n'avez
pas besoin de persévérer autant que jack
london pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée sans vous prendre la tête
[Musique]
en